[Musique]
il
tout
[Musique]
cool
les
[Musique]
mon sens
non
les précédentes
le soja paiement
il fait
une décision
qui
il y a
je
le maquereau a écrit à la main une
lettre visant à absoudre alexis kohler
des chefs d'inculpation dont il fait
l'objet à mes questions pourtant très
clair sur cette affaire nicole belloubet
fait semblant de ne pas comprendre et
répond à côté pour mieux couvrir macro
nouvelles révélations accablantes de
mediapart sur le dangereux mélange des
genres entre pouvoir exécutif et
judiciaire sur une procédure concernant
le plus proche collaborateur du
président la séparation des pouvoirs est
elle trop ancien monde pour macron le
président de la république est intervenu
dans la sphère colère la question de
l'indépendance de la justice s'oppose
il y a quelque chose de pourri au
royaume de macro ni à lire mediapart
macro aurait écrit au pnf pour disculper
son collaborateur colère et pour couvrir
un mensonge d'état
il relève de la destitution alexis
kohler a été déchargé de toutes les
questions qui pouvaient concerner cette
entreprise avec laquelle il avait des
liens familiaux quand il était au
cabinet du ministre de l'économie
encore une fois il ya eu un an
d'investigations qui ont confirmé cela
je considère qu alexis colère est un
grand serviteur de l'état qu'il est
d'une probité total et ma confiance est
complète
il ne faut pas confondre la séparation
des pouvoirs qui est une règle absolue
mais là au fond si j'ai bien lu cet
article c'est une sorte d'attestation
d'employeur
cela se fait tous les jours en france
qu'un employeur atteste sur un
collaborateur ou sur un autre
[Musique]
ce